travis um as we said right before the
commercial we have someone very special
standing by
um that's a huge fan of yours and if
it's okay
do you mind like standing by of course
okay
um marcel dezubo is a firefighter
paramedic and a huge fan of travis's
he and his seven-month-old little one
daughter lane have gone viral
for their hilarious and very sweet
drumming
videos on tick tock and everybody's
obsessed take a look
[Music]
please welcome marcel disabo and his
daughter
lane hey andrew
oh hi
[Music]
this is lane oh hi
wayne and so nice to meet you marcel
marcel i am so excited um
we're obsessed with your videos how did
this all start
oh thank you yeah actually you know we
were just
hanging out at the kitchen table one
morning and i
just randomly said hey let's make a
video we were just having fun
you know at the kitchen table and sure
enough here we are
well i see that you're inspired by
drumming
and i understand you're a fan of travis
barker as well
oh yeah for sure travis parker's awesome
i've always
always listened to him well
if it's okay do you mind if i uh bring
him in for a second
what really yeah oh my god
how's it going man that video is awesome
oh thank you so much man you're such an
inspiration for me
i'm kind of lost for words right now but
thanks for being on the show
nah you guys are awesome i did the same
thing with my kids
they'd be like what are you doing that's
so awesome
and obviously like uh you know thank you
for all your services and stuff that's
awesome
oh thanks man i'm happy to do my job i i
really love it
it's fun and i love hanging out with
this little one
i mean marcel not only are you an
amazing father but you're on the front
lines as a paramedic and a firefighter
how is everything right now in in your
amazing heroic world oh it's going great
you know
um yeah obviously the the the covid
thing happened last year and
things got a little difficult you know
the world can't stop because
you know that's what i enjoy doing and
that's what i'm going to continue to do
every day
travis you and i are parents that seems
like one happy
kid i have to say yes i
live for that like time with my kids to
have it back so
oh i can't even imagine it's it's
beautiful oh thank you so much
she just seems to love these sticks i
got her these
he's her own little drumsticks they're
pink
oh that's so cool um any tips travis for
lane so i started playing drums when i
was
three or four and we couldn't afford a
drum kit but we just had pots and pans
and that was
my drum set for years for like a good
three years so um i mean it seems like
she
already enjoys it so that's a good sign
that's that's all i wanted to do that
that's the only thing that put a smile
on my face
maybe in a couple years we can upgrade
to some pots and pans
yeah yeah sounds perfect and doable
marcel i'm so grateful that you and lean
came by i'm so glad your video went
viral i think it went viral because it's
bringing everybody joy and that's what
we need right now as well as your heroic
service
thank you for taking care of us oh no
thank you for having me it's been a
pleasure it's been awesome
and travis i just again want to thank
you so much
for our awesome time together um and
travis's wonderful company barker
wellness which is gorgeous and effective
and
beautifully thought out is available now
and it'll be up on our website
as well directing you to his website
so thank you for coming and telling us
um about that
awesome thank you all right thank you so
[Music]
much